let's talk about how to get rid of your
stiffness
in your body and feel younger again uh
when i was
28 i was very very stiff i felt very
very
old i felt like i was in my 50s now i'm
in my 50s i'm 55 and i feel like
i'm in my 20s back then i had a lot of
issues going on
and i was consuming a lot of
carbohydrates and
that is something that i assume that
everyone knows about
if you're doing a high carb diet that'll
stiffen your joints up and create all
sorts of
inflammation so i'm just assuming you
know that we're going to talk about the
other common causes of stiffness one is
too much iron
okay so iron creates a lot of
inflammation it creates
problems in your liver and iron comes
from many sources like
a lot of things are fortified with iron
especially if you're doing
grains which i don't recommend you do or
even pasta and things like that
also supplements some of the top
multivitamin mineral complexes come with
way too much
iron iron doesn't really get eliminated
from our bodies very well
especially in men and accumulates and it
creates fibrosis and inflammation and
eventually even cirrhosis of the liver
but it will definitely stiffen you up so
what you want to do is avoid iron now if
you have a problem with excess iron
you also want to probably avoid red meat
because it's loaded with iron
it's just a side note and you'll you'll
notice your inflammation will start
coming down
okay number two so-called vegetable oils
are really seed oils they're grain oils
and you want to avoid them corn soy
canola cotton seed also
safflower and sunflower or omega-6
these are omega-6 fatty acids and
they're very inflammatory
and they're badly processed with
solvents and
these are gmo as well and they can
create a lot of
stiffness in your body so you want to
avoid these for sure you want to replace
them
especially when you're in cooking with
butter and maybe olive oil
and coconut oil on your salad you can
use olive oil but just realize that
the majority of olive oil sold out there
is not
pure olive oil and i put a link down
below of a video
that i did in olive oil so you can have
all the data on that but the point is
that
if you're doing too much omega-6 and not
enough omega-3
you're going to have an imbalance and
create a lot of inflammation in the body
and stiffness there's a great test
that you can do to pick up your ratios
but i suggest you start consuming more
fatty fish
sardines cod of oil and fish oil
be careful about fish oils do not do
like some
low quality fish oil you want to do
something high-end because
you get what you pay for and there's a
lot of bad things in these very
inexpensive fish oils that you want to
avoid
so you want to get a high quality
collard oil that'll probably be the best
you can get
but the point is that this will give you
the omega-3 fatty acids
omega-3 fatty acid deficiencies create
inflammation pain and stiffness
so if you're on a low fat diet
or you're a vegan realize that these
omega-3
fatty acids mostly come from fish
sardines you can get them from algae
but you would have to get that in a
supplement but the point is that these
are essential fatty acids they're
important
and if you're not consuming them or you
don't like fish or whatever
that can create inflammation right there
because you're going to be missing the
omega-3 fatty acids
and the two primary ones i'm going to
focus on are dha and epa
so just by taking this you'll notice
that your stiffness will be much better
probably within one to two weeks
next one is increasing vitamin k2 what
is that
that is a type of vitamin that drives
calcium
out of the joints out of soft tissue
into the bone
and it works with vitamin d3 vitamin d3
also helps inflammation in your muscle
and it gets rid of pain in your joints
as well so
you might get great benefit by taking d3
and i always like to take them together
what do we see as a common thread
between this one and this one and this
one
well we're dealing with fats right so
if you have difficulty
digesting fats okay because there's
something going on with your
gallbladder what's going to happen is
you're not going to be able to absorb
the essential fatty
acids from the cod liver oil or the fish
oil or even the fatty fish
so you're deficient so there's a lot of
people who have
stiffness pain and inflammation and even
fibromyalgia
from a gallbladder problem and it's
usually going to be on the right side
in fact it's always going to go on the
right side on the left side it's
probably going to be more of a
pancreatic type thing because the
pancreas and the
gallbladder work together the
gallbladder
concentrates bile bile is only made by
your liver primary bile is made by your
liver
secondary is made by your friendly
bacteria in your large intestine
but what happens is the bile is created
it goes down to the gallbladder where
it's concentrated
and then when you eat it's supposed to
be released and it's supposed to break
down
the fats into smaller particles
where now the pancreas can release
lipase its enzyme
to take it down to even smaller
particles so then your body can absorb
it in the small intestine
so a lot of the fat is absorbed in the
small intestine
and then if we keep going in the small
intestine right before we hit the large
intestine
that's when a lot of the bile is
supposed to be reabsorbed
and recycled so bile
is recycled about 95 percent so if
there's inflammation
in that part of your small intestine
then you're going to be boweled
deficient as well
so you can be bile deficient from a
problem in your liver
the gallbladder your intestine or the
large colon
so there's a lot of other reasons why
you might be deficient in bile
the point is that if you're
deficient in bile you're going to get
stiff despite taking
these remedies right here and so i'm
going to put some links down below
to increase your awareness of the
gallbladder in relationship to pain and
inflammation stiffness
but i had that problem for 12 years i
didn't even know it was related
until one day i learned about it and
never had pain there
ever again a good indicator to know if
you have a gallbladder problem is a
fullness or tightness underneath the
right rib cage
the remedy is to take purified balance
salts if you want more information i put
a link down below on that
but bile will help the absorption of
these right here so stiffness
a lot of times is related to a lack of a
certain fat
or the digestion of a certain fat
all right thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto absolutely not karen
and it's an immune system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it